video we'll be talking about
trinucleotide repeat expansion disease
these are set of genetic disorder caused
by abnormal expansion of trinucleotide
repeats within a gene sequence we'll be
first talking about the disease names
the repeat types mode of inheritance and
the pneumonics to remember them
eventually we would move into the
details of all these disease and discuss
the pathology in details first we'll
talk about Huntington disease then
myotonic destrophy then fragile ex
syndrome then Frederick Ataxia these are
the four important diseases we are going
to discuss in this context so in
Huntington disease the repeat type is c
a and the mode of inheritance in is
autosomal dominant that means at every
generation there is a high risk that the
that particular individual in that
generation would be affected the
pneumonic to remember is coded has low a
and Gaba myotonic destrophy results due
to ctg multiple repeats and it is an
autosomal dominant disorder and the
pneumonic to remember this is cataract
stopy which is early blinding in males
and gonadal atrophy in males and reduced
fertility in
females fragile X syndrome which is due
to the cgg repeat and it's an exling
dominant males are more prone to have
this disease so the pneumonic to
understand this is sing giant gonads
Frederick attaka is due to the GAA type
of uh repeats and it's an autosomal
recessive disorder where a taxi gate
could be
found okay in case of trinucleotide
repeat expansion disease there is a
common theme that is true for any any
kind of these disorders so obviously
normal uh Gene encodes for normal
protein and that protein is functional
it folds properly and form a functional
enzyme let's say in case of
trinucleotide repeat disorder what
happens there is a multiple repeat of
these TR nucleotides which lead to
expansion of these nucleotide these
multiple amino acids in a protein
sequence once there are too many of
these repetitive amino acids it leads to
aggregation now these proteins might not
be functional or it turns out to be
toxic for the cell and this theme is
common for all these four disease it's
just the uh name of the gene is
different like there are different genes
which are involved in four these four of
these different diseases so let's talk
about the Huntington disease Huntington
disease or Huntington kodia involves uh
basically Progressive neuro degeneration
and there are motor coordination problem
it's a genetic disorder and inherited
one so this is how a normal and
Huntington brain look like it can affect
motor abilities movement and motor
control cognition and psychotic problems
are also common in chromosome 4 there is
a gene known as
Huntington so this Gene has several CAG
repeats the normal to level limit is 10
to 25 repeats and this particular Gene
uh sometimes have mutations which has 40
to 80 repeats instead of these 10 to 20
repeats as a result what happens these
particular uh proteins are now
non-functional can form aggregate which
is toxic to a neuron known as medium
spiny neurons um in the basal ganglia so
basically these medium spiny neurons are
actually uh garic neurons they fine-tune
the motor movement when there is a
problem in this Gene the gabic F
functionality is gone there is low Gaba
and that leads to uncontrolled
undesirable movement that is pretty much
common for Huntington disease there is
problem in voluntary and involuntary
movement for example uh involuntary
jerking or writing like movement which
is known as scoria there is also defect
in um other involuntary movements for
example uncontrolled hand movement uh
slow and unusual eye movement rapid eye
movement Etc also there could be
muscular destrophy or muscle tone
problem found in this particular disease
if you want to learn more about the
Huntington disease I have a link which
is present in the ey button click on
that right now now we would move on to
understand the myotonic destrophy it's
just a different disease but the theme
is same there is repeat expansion and
that repeat expansion is not good for
cellular physiology let's try to
understand that so obviously in this
case
as the name suggest there is myotonic
destrophy there are problems with muscle
tones so you can see in myotonic
destrophy there is a decreased mus
muscular tone and there is another
typical muscle contraction and
relaxation related problem normally what
happens when you clinch your fist you
can open it instantly but in case of M
myotonic destrophy
this thing is delayed for example the
arm remain clinched for a long time
before you can open it again okay so
basically mutation in dmpk gene is one
of the uh problem also mutation in cnbp
gene is causal for this matonic
destrophy there are two categories one
is known as dm1 another know is one is
known as dm2 so in the first one we can
find ctg repeats or ctg trinucleotide
repeats which has expanded and in the
second case in the cnbp gene instead of
TR nucleotide there is four nucleotide
repeat expansion for example cctg repeat
expansion okay so this tells us that
it's a nucleotide repeat expansion
disorder but what is the pathology it's
important to know that dmpk and cnbp
genes are present in two different
chromosomes okay dmpk and cnbp produce
this kind of mRNA which has several of
these repeats these mRNA actually form
hair pin which sequesters many RNA
binding protein on them it works like a
scaffold for other protein to interact
now now what is the consequence of this
kind of B binding it leads to RNA
toxicity because it sequ sequesters RNA
binding protein and it prevents
basically
spliceosomes or it prevents the process
of splicing that's how it can affect it
can lead to aggregation of these RNA
binding protein inside the nucleus and
it forms nuclear Speckles as well okay
so basically genes basically RNA
metabolism Associated molecules such as
muscle blind these particular proteins
are highly affected in this
disorder now there are two subtypes of
myotonic distrophy as we mentioned
earlier myotonic myotonic distrophy 1
and distrophy 2 so myotonic destrophy
one happens due to mutations in dmpag
gen or repeat expansions in dmpag gen
and dm2 happens due to uh four
nucleotide expansion in cnbp
gene so the symptoms have for both these
my Tropic dist has similarities but uh
dm1 is more severe compared to dm2 and
for example dm1 has a adulthood onset
whereas dm2 can also have a adulthood
onset but sometimes it could be also
adolescent or childhood onset as well
now let's talk about the clinical
symptoms of myotonic destrophy in when
it comes to clinical symptoms there are
cognition impairments cataracts
arhythmia respiratory difficulties
gastrointestinal problems muscle
weakness Etc
now let's talk about Frederick's aaia
Frederick's aaia is a rare Progressive
neurological disorder that affects the
nervous system and heart so these are
the two region which are affected in
this disorder in this case there is
difficulty with balance and coordination
weakness of the muscle
disera and it was actually described by
Nicholas
Frederick several years ago so it its
incidence is 3 to four per 100,000 birs
and its onset is childhood or
adolescence males are more susceptible
iology uh involves it's a autosomal
recessive inheritance pattern GAA
trinucleotide is expanded and basically
in a gene known as fraxin and there is a
reduced expression of the fraxin protein
which is absolutely essential for
mitochondrial function so obviously
mitochondrial dysfunction is one of the
underlying cause of the pathology
disregulation of iron metabolism
increased susceptibility to oxidative
stress all these things are the
complications in this disease so
generally people die with cardiomyopathy
and prognosis is not really good in this
case and life expectancy is reduced if
you want to learn more about Frederick's
aaia the link would be in the eye button
anyway it's a progressive aaia there
would be gate instability limp
incoordination disartria heart and
Tremors kind of problems ocular
abnormalities like nagas dysphasia Etc
Etc now there are also non-motor
manifestation like cognitive impairment
pyretic problems peripheral neuropathy
Etc complications generally why death
happens is basically the
cardiomyopathy now genetic cause of
Frederick Ataxia involves uh the ex
repeat expansion in the fxing gene
normally fxing Gene give rise to F taxin
protein which is really important and uh
important for incorporating iron sulfur
clusters in the mitochondria which is
very essential for metabolically active
tissues like neuron and liver so these
fraction proteins are enriched in neuron
heart and pancreas so obviously when
fraction proteins are less or produced
in a inadequate format all these
specific cell types are affected so when
the repeat expansion happens like more
than 100 repeats it it is pathological
so functional functionally the fraxin
protein is compromised if you want to
learn more about Frederick aaia click on
the I button next we talk about fragile
X syndrome but very briefly we would
have a different detailed video which
would be found in I button to learn more
about it in fragile X syndrome the uh
fmr1 Gene which is located in the X
chromosome has these nucleotide
expansion repeats so fragile X mental
retardation protein is really important
for normal brain function and fragile X
syndrome is an exling genetic disorder
so males are more
susceptible and get affected more than
the females because they have only one
chromosome when it comes to the symptoms
there are intellectual disabilities
behavioral challenges like hyperactivity
social anxiety attention problems
difficulty with social interaction and
there are physical characteristics which
are very typical to these patients for
example they have long face large ears
and prominent jaw or forehead however
these features can be subtle and
sometimes there are uh behavioral uh
problems which are more prominent in
these particular disease but all this is
due to that trinucleotide repeat
expansion in the fmr1 gene so I hope
this video was useful and we talked
about four important disease where
trinucleotide repeat expansion is the
key cause of pathology I hope this video
was useful give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
see you in next video
come